so for more than a year now really since
Donald Trump's 2016 election I've been
saying and others have been saying that
Donald Trump is a symptom of the problem
but Trump is not the problem in and of
itself so as an example to start
thinking about this Donald Trump didn't
create anti intellectualism
and pseudo-intellectual ISM but he
invigorated it he benefited from the
fact that sudo and anti intellectualism
has been growing in the United States
for decades and he actually continues to
maintain this core and sort of immutable
base of support at least in part because
of the anti and pseudo-intellectual ISM
that pervades that base another example
Donald Trump didn't create extremism
although he certainly has fomented it
but what he did do was coalesce the
extremism allow the extremists to feel
more emboldened and comfortable in the
public eye more so than they have in a
very long time and there's a really nice
piece and The Guardian that I read
yesterday by British journalist Gary
Young who by the way if you've not heard
of him Google or even search on YouTube
Gary Young Richard Spencer and you'll
see some pretty interesting
conversations between young and white
nationalists Richard Spencer and Gary
Young really spells this out in this
Guardian piece and it's a much broader
picture even than young Paints Young
says forget about the rise of Trump for
a second if you are shocked by the
global rise of the right then you
weren't paying attention and he's
exactly right and what this means is
that Trump brexit Modi winning
re-election in India the nationalist
anti-immigration party's in multiple
European countries this is something
that we were seeing the sort of
precursors to for quite some time and
Jung points out that if you look at the
people who were doing the voting in
those countries of course they were
eventually going to have an impact these
are Gary Young's words from the article
quote I'd like to focus on one thing
that unites them that the countries
which keep producing these shocks are
every bit as race
xenophobic and discriminatory as their
voting habits suggests this is not some
new virus it's a susceptibility to a
chronic illness that has crippled us for
years these electoral victories are
largely but not exclusively the products
of those age-old prejudices not because
everyone who voted for them was racist
but because all the racists who did go
to the polls voted for them the
intensity of that racism is now growing
as the victors use their podiums and
dispatch boxes to amplify their their
bigotry giving confidence and license
for people to spread the their poison
this is not shocking and there's a lot
of blame to go around
we're partially to blame for it okay
Obama was elected and too many people
said we've solved something something
big could have been racism could have
been whatever but the problems continued
and Obama was very limited in what he
was able to do he was also limited in in
some senses by what he tried to do and
in the end there was Republican
obstruction the right wing went crazy
very successfully ginning up all sorts
of racial and ethnic animus and then in
comes Donald Trump and all of these
horrible disgusting enclaves that were
invigorated against Barack Obama are now
feeling vindicated and empowered and
emboldened and we're seeing the effect
of that we're seeing the effect of that
in terms of the victories of these white
nationalists and more generally
nationalist xenophobic anti-immigration
parties in Europe we're seeing it in the
emboldened increase in hate crimes and
anti-semitism and all the rest of it in
the United States and that's one piece
of it the Democratic Party is definitely
to blame in the United States
Obama won in 2008 and then the
Democratic establishment or much of it
takes this attitude of let's compromise
on stuff with Republicans because we're
bigger than they are and we're better
than them and you know what we are to a
degree but they weren't going to
compromise on a lot of the things that
the Democratic Party thought or try
to compromise on and meanwhile the
Democratic Party while failing to
actually get a bunch of stuff done
because of this bogus idea of
compromising with Republicans maintained
the pro corporate status quo in a lot of
other areas while having this massive
angry movement growing against them
under Barack Obama and then here we are
with Donald Trump not as the problem but
as the sort of in a sense logical end
result of the circumstances that were
fomented in part by the Democratic Party
under Barack Obama and of course the
majority of the blame goes to the
extremists like I want to be really
clear about that
I don't do this both sides stuff on the
show when there is a both sides thing
I'll still say that even though there is
some blame on both sides here's where
the majority of the blame is you know we
can talk about the left under Obama we
can talk about the Democratic Party the
majority of the blame is the extremists
since they are the ones that we are
actually fighting against here so in any
case we should be disgusted by the rise
of the extremist xenophobic right we
should be angry we should be activated
and we should be doing things to push
back this applies in Europe this
certainly applies in the United States
when it comes to the upcoming 2020
election but being surprised is the last
thing we should be and what's really
important I mean listen we got to get
Trump out okay there's no question about
that but when we think about the future
of homo sapiens
in the modern world of nation-states and
governments and all of this other stuff
that makes up today's status quo we
shouldn't overstate Trump as being the
problem but rather a sort of predictable
predictable and logical end result of
decades of anti-intellectualism and
ginning up these serviced oral responses
with the Republican conservative
red-meat we should think about it as a
symptom of the problem that we want to
solve rather than the problem itself
really good piece by Gary yang which I
encourage you to read one of today's
sponsors is impeach the card slap game
you can't slap Donald Trump in real life
but you can slap him in this
really funny and intelligent two-player
card game and you can get it for 10% off
at david pakman.com slash impeach
impeach the card game is perfect for
having friends over hanging out with
family members who have a sense of humor
about trump we've been playing it at my
place I really don't think you'd be able
to find a game that does a better job of
satirizing today's political climate in
such an intelligent way I've had a ton
of fun with it I think you will too
you can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary in the game we were talking
to the creators of the game and they
said one of the goals was that players
might even learn something new as they
play I think it would make a perfect
gift for anyone really of any political
orientation because of how clever it is
don't forget Father's Day is coming up
and when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach you'll get 10% off the
game but you can also get 10% off any of
the hilarious clothing and accessories
in the online store including t-shirts
coffee mugs tote bags all featuring
funny original political cartoons about
the president get a super fun and witty
gift for yourself or someone you know
whether it's impeach the card slap game
or any of the other awesome stuff in the
gift shop
and get 10% off of all of it when you go
to david pakman.com slash impeach